hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast symbiotic programming of
plants for stress tolerance with fungal
endophyte s-- altering the future of
food security political stability and
poverty it is presented by rusty
rodriguez PhD CEO of adaptive symbiotic
technologies I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Rodriguez I
will now turn the presentation over to
him good day it's a pleasure to be
speaking to you today I want to talk to
you about research that my colleagues
and I have been doing for many years
looking at how plants is back to stress
in nature I want to start by defining or
fumbling the fight for our freedom
mumble endophytes are microscopic fungi
that live inside plants and though their
enzyme fight the plant and they reside
entirely inside the plants in between
the cells which are known as the
nonvascular a blast so let's just get
started on how this all began and how
led us to developing technology for
mitigating impacts of climate change on
agriculture in years ago when we started
looking at planets in nature and trying
to understand how they adapt to stress
and the most remarkable part of this is
that all plants have the ability to
adapt to stress but very few do so the
question is how do plants adapt we know
that as stress goes up biodiversity
Constance's
a higher distress the theory of the
species that appear to be able to adapt
to these vessels and conventional wisdom
has told us for a century that the
plants adapt with normal Darwinian
process where they adjust their nuclear
genomes and slowly adapt over time
well to put it in perspective of
agriculture climate mitigation has been
of interest to farmers since the
inception of Agriculture ten thousand
years and the only one of the Holy
Grails of Agriculture is to generate Wow
crime and resilient crops and over the
last 20 or 30 years is been a tremendous
amount of effort and interest put into
this to generate crops that are drought
tolerant on either by breeding traits
from native plants that have adapted to
these stresses into commercial crops or
through genetic modifications however
neither of these approaches have been
very successful and we believe that the
reason is is that the underlying
mechanism for this was employed the
underlying mechanism was that the plants
were adapting on their own that in fact
they were acting as individuals
modifying their genomes and adapting
slowly over time now over the last
hundred years and then 50 years there
have been brilliant scientific minds
that have supported generating
information indicating that mrs. Haley
had worked in Mesa that the organisms
act as individuals the only problem with
that is that in nature there is no such
thing as on plants just like all the
animals are symbiotic with
microorganisms and in the plant
agreement these symbiotic organisms or
it can be bacterial viral different
types of fungi that can be simply
answered points in addition just like
animals the planters in different if you
will stand by out of habitats to
microorganisms there's the root zone or
notices rhizosphere that surrounds the
root zone
there's the canopy of a plant the foliar
surfaces and then there's in some of the
plants and these these symbiotic
associations can play out in many
different ways
and they can span and team from
beneficial or mutualistic between both
partners or it can be antagonistic or
parasitic where a benefits alone and is
a detriment to the others and you see
the list here of the different types of
symbiosis all defined by the benefits
that positive negative or neutral that
arrive to wonder with the species now
remarkably these associations have been
in existence since plants moved on to
land and this is supported on the fossil
records where fungi have been identified
in great sections of plants well on top
of the fact that all of the plants are
symbiotic with microstamping organisms
the fungi the dissociative plants and
their unique set of dynamics that they
can operate by and one of the things
that they can do is they can switch
symbiotic lifestyles
where which are defined by the benefits
that I showed you in the last slide
here's a good
example of them of work done by avarice
and white some years ago where they were
looking at a pong uncle system the
fungus is the podium in the tropics and
what they were finding was it when the
palm trees there they were growing in
the sound the Deponia acted as a
pathogenic fungus because these lesions
impacted the growth and development of
palms could kill them as well hours they
move those palms into the shady then
that symbiosis became a neutral where
the the fungus benefited the plants and
growth and thickness a beautiful example
about environmental conditions and
influency outcome of the similar system
from one somatic lifestyle to another
all driven by how the fungus responds to
the environment another version of this
is shown that Tobiah symbiotic
lifestyles can switch based on the
genetic influence of the plant here's a
table showing a number of color
contrecoup species these are all
pathogens and the disease hosts that
they are pathogenic I'm shown next to
each indecision we did a partnership
opping experiment many years ago where
we took for example Kalachakra command
and then we should have a concurrent
diseases be watermelons and cantaloupes
with anyone and we put him on tomatoes
to ask a colonized maybe was and if they
were pathogenic on these tomatoes if
they are not but they were deemed that
was that these pathogens could a
systematically colonize
juan diseases switch their lifestyles
and on from being Capuchin
to being beneficial so depending another
genetic landscape that the microorganism
see that can cause lifestyle switching
as well and it can span that continuum I
talked about trees
well the studies that we made early on
led to a series of questions we began to
ask about how plants and major the other
was stress and there's symbiotic
partners and we begin by looking at
these plant communities that live in
geothermal soils in Yellowstone National
Park
in the state of Wyoming now these are
our hot soils where steam comes out from
negative magma chambers below so that
the summertime temperatures can get up
around 65 seen and where time
temperatures can drop down in the low
20s but they never freeze and there is a
small plant community that lives there
about ten species that can tolerate this
extreme variation in temperature and I
should point out that 65 seems about the
new temperature to cut the turkey and so
they're pretty hot but we look at plants
throughout Yellowstone Park to ask
anything recently I'm looking these high
stressful condition and we know that all
of the plants we looked at and one
fungal endophyte inside of them the
fungus is no mr. bule area for too broad
and we grew in a need in between the
cells of the plants and it since it
wasn't in all of the plants we lived up
it was the dominant in the fight it may
be the question of whether or not a
clearly significant or a little
ecologically performance of plants and
so what we did was we started with some
laboratory experiments where me bill
means the thermal sort of simulators in
the top left where we eat the roots of
plants
20 temperature we desired and wicks from
the soil the plants were growing in
downed engines these brown tones that
were filled with water so we were able
to separate drought stress from each
dose and you can see in the panel's next
about the S stands for some wild and the
M stands for man somatic
we were heating these root zones to 70
°c during the day turning 37 19 well the
semiotic plants survived throughout the
entire experiment which was about 10
babies the non-symmetric plants died
within the date so this was at least
laboratory indication
there this association might have a
significant ecological role for the
adaptation of these plants in nature
well to verify that we went back to
Yellowstone to our field site there in
the lower panel on the Left we dug up a
thousand pounds of soil back you know
pasteurized to eliminate the microbes
within that sort of carrying back in
putting in these autumn 'less plastic
containers with a separator we the
middle of it and then we filled it with
soil we brought back and put in either
symbiotic plans or non-semitic plants
and these plants are the native species
the tropical plant grass that grows in
posta we put him in the ground we came
back in here later and what we found was
that if I ants were put in the ground
without the fungus in them they didn't
mastermind the stresses of that soil and
backed with the plant they put on
significant biomass and with as an
indication of the fungus increasing the
thickness of these plants so this at the
time was the first example of a
symbiotic association between plants and
fungi where the fungus was involved in
the adaptation of the point and I should
point out that neither in the plane but
where the fungus can tolerate
temperatures in the land above 38 °c
when you eye on the field they can
tolerate much higher so it was not just
that the fungus was allowing for
survival plant it was also that they
simply had a communication between these
two a lot of her survival or no speech
well after that we wanted to know if
this was something specific to these
plants or to the fungus and so we first
started working with the fungus and
asking if we could move in from other
plants it is beginning what it did
inside this fence
so here's an image showing watermelon
seedlings that were grown hydroponically
at these different temperatures you can
see that the uncolonized ones can grow
up to about 38 see but well to die above
that but the ones on the right where we
added the fungus back
the colonists phones they can grow up to
50 scene without any human exponents so
not only was this the first example
where we could move this fungus in
between plants and show that the
mutation was the same and the benefits
conferred similarly this was moving the
fungus from a grassland monocot injuring
broad leaf or a united cot plant and
those two lineages of plants diverged
somewhere between 145 and 250 million
years ago
so these lineages of plants representing
human genetic differences well have the
same symbiotic communication with these
on the lingual coats suggesting that
this is highly conserved and that these
semi a communication has been the same
for an awful long time
well after we finish these studies it
prompted us to move into a number of
different habitats around the world to
look at different types of stresses
soils or other types of stresses and in
this graph or in this slide so you can
see that whether it is chemical physical
stress if you go into habitats now we
know that we can you can have some
predictive capabilities that have
planned surviving than any stress are
most likely to have funding and advice
within them exams are responsible for
stress tolerance of those plants well on
top of this we now know that if you go
into mark into environmental gradients
so this is an example of a salt
reading going from coastal beaches and
area for Washington where's one plant
species it's called American dune grass
or Lima smalis grows from the beach in
the cobbles of the English stones where
high tides can come up and inundate the
root systems it can grow up slow
this is all radiant worse-off finishes
on to Edelman table and but we looked at
the end of mites associate and what we
found was that the planets exchanged
it's been delights as in Jerusalem from
one on the beach that conferred very
high levels of stress tolerance or salt
tolerance to eventually ones in the
slope which didn't ensure soft on us at
all but what these invites didn't do is
they optimized the fitness of the plant
along the rating so we did super cell
transplant experiments to show that at
any point along this gradient these
hands these perspectives of endophytes
to survive and to reproduce if you
exchange those any points that are there
Fitness is greatly reduced
we call this symbiotic modulation it's
another dynamic aspect of this
association well how does this all
happen this is what happens in planes
when they are exposed to stress all day
aerobic organisms when their HIPPA
stress experience and metabolic
imbalance and what is normally made at
very low levels because all much I
becomes made it a much higher level he's
gonna be active oxygen species these are
are very important molecules for
signaling there is aspects of the
physiological outcomes throughout an
organism but at high levels are very
toxic at low lows on as accessory
signaling molecules when the levels go
up what they do is they also signal the
initiation of a series of stress
response Cascades
things like the production of ethylene
their anticipation oscillates in an
intent for the plans to mitigate the
impacts of stress the stress of their
experience and what we found was in it
if you have the right end of hide inside
the plants then they don't experiences
increase in reactive oxygen so this pain
along the lower left they I just brought
up shows you what happens to meet this
staking out a plan
when they are stressed or not that's the
plus or minus sign and then floated upon
a solution of an herbicide called
paraquat the parrot what mrs. reactive
oxygen responds and causes the bleaching
of Florida you can see with the NS or
non symbiotic leaf disks from plants
that are stressed floated on paraquat
turned completely white in the upper
side if they're not stressed they stay
green if you have a compatible sin by on
which confers resistance to this
freshman pose then the nudists they can
read whether they're stressed or not and
if you have a endophyte in the plant
which does not compete or tolerance to
specific stress um those those these
discs also reach a point while under
stress and they don't than the absence
of this dress so as a summary cartoon
this is basically how we see things
happening inside the plants plants that
are it was stress do not have a single
ions or i'm an incompatible one have an
increase in ross they essentially freak
out when they come out every biochemical
pathway they can to try to protect
themselves but if they get right into
fight in they don't turn on those
pathways they sit there and kind of
chill out until the stress is gone and
then they bring their metabolism back in
full swing in a pretty balanced manner
and they they continue to grow you look
at how they respond to biotic responses
so those stresses I just showed you were
all
abiotic things like heat assault or
temperature if you expose plans to
pathogenic organisms what they doing is
something very different and inviting to
fight inside of them the in defense and
as a biological suitable where they
activate the plant defense systems very
rapidly and very powerful so the grass
below you can see in red what happens to
plants that have an end if I exposed to
a pathogen reading into fight then kicks
on the defense systems the plant walls
off the packaging and is unaffected the
panels up above
show you what happens in once American
somatic plants that are exposed to
various antigen the new lions in the
grass below and show you what happened
to the Monson Eric plants and they will
respond to the pathogen but they do it
slowly over time and the pathogens just
take advantage of that and are able to
Acosta see if we look at what happens
has been plants with regard to gene
expression appliances close to drown
stresses this is what we see in upper
panel you see there's a sense of tune so
you have on synthetic plants in your new
hand some plants starting starting
symbiotic plants then once it better
plans similar complaints exposed to
extreme drought stress non-semantic
plants exposed to extreme drought stress
you can see the non-synthetic plants are
all wilted they're dying the symbiotic
plants are showing the impacts of the
drought stress of the leaves still
retain all the church and they are
viable well if we look at gene
expression patterns there they are
enormously different between these these
different treatments though the in the
fight in this case is for turtle 60
that's from the Yellowstone situation
these are exposed to John stress you can
see that in the Venn diagram on both
lower right there's virtually no overlap
between these another three different
reasons he with a non-symmetric that was
drowned and the finding supposed to
travel or the drought recover but they
all have very fun unique gene expression
patterns on their own so when you put a
fungus in the plant the gene expression
permanent changes the physiology changes
back you can really compare a somatic
plant with one symbiotic plant just
looking at biochemistry physiology the
plant or the gene expression patterns
you would leave they might mean to think
that other different species all over
the same thing the only difference is
the presence or absence well he's done
all this research we realize that
and elucidated potential mechanisms for
mitigating impacts of climate change in
plans
and we were able to gain interest in
this concept in the agriculture problem
and so in 2013 we expanded a company
packaging the Redmond we ate to test a
device in determine if they could be
used to make the culture and we began
the development of pipeline club I am
sure the company has an active somatic
technologies and we're in Seattle
Washington well we started in 2012
testing manager and we expanded it every
year as you can see in this map all the
red dots indicate where where we've
tested and somewhere in the ocean
because of translation between the neck
the slide deck ice and what ended up the
death we're testing in various
continents in many countries and what we
have seen so far is that it when the
stress levels are flying there the
benefits are calm and balanced your
benefits are seen in virtually all soil
tones all climate zones
we've only 24 different species of crops
crop genetics don't seem to matter and
wider when was Jessa's hat show you
something that ever since that and then
what happens when that stress is
eliminated as well so there's an example
of some field evaluation by Nature
there's specifics about the evaluations
and bottom of slides and then on these
slides what you will see is either R Bar
ranch there's no grass where each flower
represents a field test
and the y-axis in each case here is new
beds between the buyers are treated and
untreated plants so what
we see here is what happens to yield as
stress goes up this is shown for for a
monocot corn and you got cotton to show
you the results of this thing we have
with a large average yield increases as
in this case even water or heat stress
increases we have something called win
rate which is basically of all the
trials you win how many you've exceeded
your expectations the expectations are
shown there's four simply but the point
here is and if stress goes that the
benefits can no and this is represented
visually in this later where you can see
the the effects of voucher on corn in
this case these are in the field plots
that were done in South Dakota in the US
and you can see the my my shirt is still
very green in August after it very
strongly
ingredients on or is he controls the
untreated plants are all brown and the
sentencing with this plant or drying out
and so there will be an enormous
difference between these we were elated
for multitude but that's a visual of the
types of results that we see out there
now one of the interesting things if we
see also this then ancestors goes up
before there are negative in tanks on
the untreated controls there are
additional benefits of the bio so this
graph bar graph represents an amazing
experiment where we needed either with
100 percent 75 percent or 50 percent of
normal
irrigation levels on corn in humanism
and you can see that when we dropped
near nation levels from a hundred
percent to 75 we actually got higher
yields with the buyers are treated
honored 67 bushels per acre where the
lower white one
or the bushels per acre of the on the
untreated controls didn't really change
much with why I'm sure went up
significantly so this is just an example
of how we see the impacts of stress
increasing benefits that the fungus in
first of the plants and and below now
this is just a schematic of how we
hypotheticals Connecticut had me
visualize this a stress goes up the
yield benefits go but the Irish are
treated and then of course as the
untreated control state enacted the
difference between them becomes greater
and greater and at some point this trust
becomes so great that everything goodbye
so this will mitigate the impacts of
climate change does not vaccinate the
plants against any climate impact plants
will still need someone and they can
still only tolerate temperatures up to
certain ones okay what happens when the
stress goes away this is what we see
[Music]
increases what we down as do the wing
roots so we drop the leg raise from
above money to around 70 we drop that is
in corn here let me draw the energy from
about 26% to three and a half percent
some of it ends up in the negative
responses and we don't know why that
occurs that that's very common studies
across big geographic areas so that's
the difference between the stress goes
away and we believe that in normal
conditions and low genetics of the host
then we play a bigger role in the
outcome of these associations that when
the stress is high we see that
disappeared so we tested this on a large
array of plants now many locations
around the world
this graph shows you the difference
between spring wheat and winter wheat is
really no difference there
this is all your loose dress but the
table there shows you all of the plant
species that we are field tested so far
working to expand this continually as
interest continue to the okay well one
of the other things that we have seen is
that the buyer can benefit plans
nutritionally and they can also converse
off level of salt tolerance and cold
tolerance depends the nutritional
experiments are very interesting the
very simple debating but basically what
we do is we taking on synthetic plants
or treated plants and we plant them in
soils deployed fertilizer and then we
ask how much biomass and the plants
produce as you can see in these images
at least under controlled conditions
these more plants treated by answer why
don't ask to cater to one somatic
controllers if we expose plants that are
treated versus not to see water levels
of sodium chloride
I'm sure cos plants against the salt
water and if we drop temperatures to 15
C or lower in the lower panel on the
right you can see that the island sugar
the green bars germination rates of
those scenes either high or is the
control of water well this year we were
able to begin testing this in the field
we had a lot of cold stress early on and
the farmers all across the whole world
and here in the US what does that
divinely share treated plants
germinated faster and they were out of
the grounds to clear out of the ground
about 3 inches before the checks the
untreated plants in the intro encourage
this then led to bigger plants around
season and the bigger ears on these corn
plants that were treated as well so it's
our first validation in the field of
cold tolerance now
the nutritional benefits are also really
interesting in men able to generate a
lot of data this year looking at
so here's an example for of the winter
wheat started spring wheat where we
under yield energy increases where we
untreated control plants that are below
40 million and I notice this butchers
burger as well
we have my own trip treated plants which
are about 15 that means a nutrient mix
these are micro organisms that produce
nutrients for plants that also generates
an increasing meal but when we combine
both the lounger and nutrient community
migrates we get a significant now we've
interpreted this for a long time as a
result of the earlier slide I showed you
where by major increases the nutrient
use efficiency of the plants that's why
I think the more biomass
when there's an illusion around compared
to untreated plants that nutrient use
efficiency when supplemented with a
nutrients community of microorganisms it
gives a much freer response than either
the community of bacteria or if we look
at this in other ways we can see that
the violent sure can expect their plants
to grow and these are some images just
to summarize a little bit what we learn
depending on when the distress is the
benefits of I'm sure will reveal
themselves in different ways if the
stress hurts right it's very early long
just like the cold tolerance I just
showed you a moment ago this is a heat
stress that if cornfields in eastern
Washington and they can plant it at the
same time it was a 240 neighbor thoughts
on the left while this treated was
untreated the upper lung which is
training shows you how the plants can be
much bigger thicker much more pens
it's below I'm just walking on the same
line between these two inch field plots
taking pictures in water summer soon as
he really big differences love them that
distress his later you may not seen
these people but you will see big
differences in Europe now a couple of
the most significant part of this is
what happens when the heat stress hits
during fertilization of flowers and what
we see is a tremendous protection of a
fertilization so many planets are very
susceptible to high temperatures during
the fertilization things-they
fertilization so you don't get seeing
and they can be sensitive to heat at
nighttime or daytime but you can see in
this panel on the network right here we
look at kuang plants that is we're
experiencing high stress during
fertilization pieces of piles of ears if
we just went along our feet in Pilates
plants it was at 375 for some thickness
demonstrating that I enjoy this with
plants during that fertilization period
ok so how can we use this type of
technology to change the future of
climate index of poverty but conflicts
around the world it's really clear and
there's some elegance
texts out on how the perfect storm
between climate and the inability to
agriculture creates a playground if you
will for food insecurity political
instability social degradation an
initial mass migration we've seen that
today with what's happened in Syria the
long term droughts in Syria interfere
with agricultural production that led to
mul nur ability of government to
incursion by outside forces which led to
a long
conflict and and the mass migration we
see the same thing at some Olinger this
one is very common outcome well a few
years ago we were able to approach you
missing ID to fund a program to take
this type of technology to for farmers
small landholders in India to try to
break this chain of poverty and improve
the outcome of agricultural productivity
for the farmers and we went out there we
got there three years ago and in the
treated seeds or total of 400 farmers of
their two staple crops one isn't one
Conte and the one on the left is is
pearl mullet and the one on the right is
among you
mung bean is also a legume which forms
associations with bacteria that connects
nitrogen then you can see in the nations
below some of the enormous differences
in plant growth or an artist that the
farmer's son and up above you see very
high wind weeds about 90 percent really
high energy increases 29% from women 56%
increase among be the farmers were
ecstatic they had not seen yields like
this in their entire lives of farming
there they actually referred to the
violence transplant medicine and we
continue to get these types of results
where in this case mistrust is on these
plants were season long water deficits
and the high temperatures temperatures
above 100 degrees through almost the
entire growing season and in a very
intermittent green well the other things
the farmers experienced was that when
they did not fertilized fields out there
and they compared bio injured treated
plants wrong in unfertilized areas to
untreated plants from fertilized areas
that either there was no difference
see there's one two five there on this
graph or there was a significant
building because the wiring sure treated
comes either way the sort of encapsulate
the nutrient that you sufficiency that
the diameter brings to the plants and
allows them to grow and in yield under
the low nutrient conditions the other
component of this and probably equally
as important is that the farmers were
most interested in comparing their
carryover seed that they generated from
previous years of growing while Markin
see now the difference between those is
there the market seed costs about eight
times with the carryover seen does and
there's not enough market seed produced
every year the two replaces two crops
and what they found was that the
carryover steam that was treated with
while insure performed at least as well
as untreated market see so they were
very ecstatic about that what a minute
was reduced costs to them and higher
higher yields and were sustainable
production well the other aspect of this
is that by nature it was developed as a
seed treatment and as a seed treatment
that obviously has to be clicked on to
see and one of the things we came to
realize working in India was that this
was almost a perfect technology to use
as a novel way of cleaning a female
empowerment program to train females to
be seat readers and opens the door for
them to foster entrepreneurship and
increase the revenues so we've been
working over there over the last two
years to begin training females in this
area that allow them to become intuitive
and agriculture in these areas and allow
them to begin to generate funding
they've been
in advance okay so where are we going
with all this we are very happy with the
climate protection that we can bring the
plants we've referred to in this climate
resilient crops that we're generating we
have within a year now we believe that
the formulations that will open the door
for generating nutritionally independent
crops as well we know that we can use
bacterial consortium now as a form of
fertilizer many people are doing this
and we combine it with nutrient use
efficiency that greatly reduces the need
for any type of synthetic fertilizer or
additional fertilizer to cross which
translate is not just to decreased the
cost for the farmers but the translates
to increased water quality coming out of
the fields that are we're also working
on new endophytes
to protect plants against packages and
to increase crop quality so in the end
early using the entire microbial basis
probably with some supplementation of
microbial fermentation products or other
organic components to take these yields
and agricultural productivity to a much
higher level of sustainability and yield
to meet future demands okay let me
finish then with just a couple of
thoughts here um in reality what I
talked about today should be much of a
surprise if we were all trained in
microbiology and and and archaea look at
this image this is from the laureate
targets down in Los Angeles since the
beautiful display of the history earth
now this our planet formed about four
billion years ago in in less than a
million years life being fallen in the
form of photosynthetic bacteria to
anaerobic close in benefactor
there was much atmosphere that at least
not much oxygen and it is estimated that
it took two billion years for those
bacteria to begin to oxygenate the
atmosphere to the levels that were
conducive for respiratory growth or
respiratory physiology like today's
plants and animals then we still have
less memorable organisms in the planet
but that blend that the oxygenation of
the atmosphere led to a an incredible
expansion of biodiversity and I'll find
him the million that about 500 million
years ago led to the composition by
plants it wasn't until after that that
animals could come as the plants and
begin to develop here but but in reality
that is extended today evolved in a
microstate and there was only one way
that it can have always two ways it
could happen either you tried to combat
the microbial stew which was just
overwhelming and required too much
energy and submitted cost or you learned
to live with it and living with it
became known mrs. M videos need to be
dissociation between complex organisms
that plants and animals and
microorganisms that live inside it is
one of the major and and few common thin
threads on this planet to light which
are better to plant some feelings there
aren't a whole lot of common threads but
this is one of them there are no plants
out there that are not so bad and in
reality they're probably no healthy
plants that have any real fitness they
allow them to adapt and survive as
inhabitants without their similar so
with that I will leave you with
a slide showing our research group and
ministy I thank you for your time and I
look forward to thank you dr. Rodriguez
for that informative presentation we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email so let's get started first
question is what controls the modulation
of symbiotic partners well-regarded
plants the plants appear to have the
ability to alter the associations so as
we look as plants grow across
environmental landscapes our
environmental gradients the plant will
kick out one partner and take in at the
new we've done this in the lab where we
can show that the plants control this
process how long does it take for
symbiosis to establish once we expose
plants to a fungal endophyte the
symbiosis is established within 24 hours
where do the endophytes live in plants
depending on the endophyte they can live
in between plant cells they do not grow
into the vasculature but they grow into
the nonvascular April past which is the
dead space between the cells are the
under fights ever a nutrient drain on
plants that's the question we don't know
if they are every nutrient on plants we
you do not have any data indicating that
they are a dream and keep in mind that
in reality there's very small amounts of
the fungus inside the plant is bio
ensure a genetically modified product no
voucher is a mixture of and who finds
that we have isolated from nature you
have time for one more question do the
bio ensure fungi establish in soil they
they do not establish in soil these
fungi involved to be endothermic they
want to be inside those plants so after
a plant was harvested it'sa messes and
we cannot pick up we cannot detect the
the fungus in soil we've done a series
of tests show that the bio mature fungi
are very long competitive under soil
conditions and they don't seem to
survive there thank you I would like to
once again thank dr. Rodriguez for his
presentation would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible Troy go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 13th 2018 you will
receive an email from laberd's letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with their colleagues who
may have missed today's event that is
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon bye